president Trump unleashes on all his
enemies and lays out his 2020 strategy
plus we have Jesse Smollett updates and
we checked the mailbag i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show well first
i want to thank everybody for continuing
to make the right side of history my new
book the number-one non-fiction book on
the New York Times bestseller list it is
still the number one nonfiction book on
all of Amazon which is astonishing Oprah
has new book work ahead of her on Amazon
still thanks to you so really thank you
so much I think it's an important book
tell all your friends about it we'll get
to all the news particularly President
Trump who just basically threw a rager
in Michigan last night it was pretty
it's thing we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
make your company better hiring it used
to be hard multiple job sites stacks of
resumes a confusing review process but
today hiren can be easy you only have to
go to one place to get it done
zip record calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one when spotlights the
top candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
can a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire
it's why we use it here at the daily
wire offices you should use it at your
business too zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire and you can try zip recruiter
for free zip recruiter again the
smartest way to hire ok so president
from basically laid out what his 2020
campaign is going to look like and
they're a good ton they're good points
and there are bad points he did it last
night in Michigan Michigan is a state he
want extraordinarly narrowly over
Hillary Clinton he beat her forty seven
point three percent to 47 percent it is
trending a little bit blue because in
the last election cycle in 2018 a lot of
Democrats won the the senatorial
candidate John James over there a really
good solid Republican candidate military
background african-american
he lost which was too bad the the fact
is that president Trump's reelection
essentially hinges on three states
Wisconsin Pennsylvania and Michigan
that's it that's the whole election he
will probably win Ohio it's debatable
whether anyone's floor it depends on the
Democrat if he loses Florida it's over
he has to hold all of the states that he
held last time except for one he can
lose Wisconsin and still win the
election he could lose Pennsylvania as
long as he holds Wisconsin and Michigan
but he cannot lose two of those three or
the election is over so Michigan is a
crucial battleground state for him in
the aftermath of the Moller reports top
line findings being released President
Trump was ready to go on a rampage and
rampage he did last night in Grand
Rapids Michigan half the rally was about
how much he hates the media and how much
he despises the people who pushed the
Russia collusion hoax and then half the
rally was dedicated to him actually
attacking the Democratic positions now
all of this is good right all of this is
good for Trump Trump's pitch in 2020 is
very simple I have been targeted like no
other president in history by the media
I have been called a Russian stooge for
two years because they couldn't get over
the fact that Hillary Clinton lost and
yet in spite of that we have made all of
these gains on the economy on foreign
policy we were rebuilding our military
we're cutting regulations we're making
it easier to do business imagine what a
second term of this will be if the media
get over themselves and actually allow
me to do the work that I need to do
that's the argument the President Trump
should be making headed into 2020 but
President Trump is nothing if not as he
likes to call himself a counter puncher
this has its upsides and it has its
downsides and so we return to campaign
Trump campaign Trump who has I have
described in the past is a hammer in
search of a nail sometimes he hits a
nail and it's very satisfying and
sometimes he hits a baby and it is far
less satisfying last night in Grand
Rapids Michigan a pent-up crowd I mean
the crowd was just ready to roar at the
slightest provocation here is the
President of the United States
describing what he called the collusion
of delusion after three years of Lies
and smears and slander the Russia hoax
is finally dead
the collusion delusion is over
the special counsel completed its report
and found no collusion and no
obstruction okay so yeah he's right
about all of this and this is a fair
ground for him too for him to go after
the media and to go after the Democrats
who lied about him for two continuous
years on this basis the president also
suggested that this was the greatest
hoax in history which frankly it may
well have been considering that the
media legitimately spent two years
proclaiming that undoubtedly there would
be evidence that he was a Russian
catspaw you heard the same thing from
members of the intelligence community it
really was astonishing you know people
talk about the failures of the
intelligence community in the lead-up to
the war in Iraq there was a widespread
intelligence consensus from Israeli
intelligence British intelligence French
intelligence German intelligence there
was widespread consensus that Saddam
Hussein was developing WMD because
Saddam Hussein wanted the world to think
that he was in fact developing WMD that
was an intelligence failure what we
watched her was not intelligence failure
what we watched here was members of the
intelligence community leveraged their
institutional credibility on behalf of a
narrative that was absolutely not true
we watched James clapper the former head
of Obama's CIA go out there in public
and suggest that he actually was the D&I
the Director of National Intelligence go
out there and suggest that he had
special knowledge that President Trump
was probably in league with the Russians
weird the same thing from John Brennan
Obama's former CIA director that he was
going to he had some inside baseball
knowledge based on his institutional
knowledge that suggested that Trump was
all of these things we watched members
of the media come out nearly every day
and simply suggest without benefit of
evidence that it was absolutely clear
the Trump campaign had thrown the
election with the help of Russia
so when Trump says this is the greatest
hoax in history there is a pretty solid
case to be made on this basis at least
in the history of American politics
promoted and perpetuated the single
greatest hopes in the history of
politics in our country okay so
obviously this is a basis for him to get
the base revved up the question is
whether this is a basis for actually
campaigning
the more Trump focuses on this going
forward and doesn't talk about his
record doesn't talk about what he has
done doesn't talk about what the
Democrats are the more he keeps the
focus on himself as victim I don't think
that that is going to be a continuing
effective strategy other than getting
the base really revved up which is good
you need to revved up base but President
Trump needs to win a bunch of voters who
are in the middle he needs to win
suburban women I'm not sure this mode
carries him here and the more worked up
he gets over this again I think that's
not great strategy I understand it on a
personal level if somebody had accused
me of what they accused President Trump
of I'd want to go out there and Club
some folks too I'd want to go out there
and Club the media like like a baby seal
rhetorically speaking but as a
politician I'm not sure this is the
smartest strategy again the more
exercise Trump gets the more off-putting
he is frankly to suburban women in
particular people he needs to win in
2020 president Trump obviously got
himself revved up he's a friendly crowd
here here he says that in continuing
probes continuing investigations are
ridiculous bull bleep he just drops him
some curse words will continue
defrauding the public with ridiculous
partisan investigations or
whether they will apologize to the
American people and join us to rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure okay all of
that is fine then he goes off the rails
and this is where he gets in too bad
Trump territory so this is a pretty good
episode actually a good Trump bad Trump
which we haven't done in a while because
the focus has largely been on the
Democrats who are vying to compete with
him all of this is okay Trump too good
from and then he gets too bad Trump and
this is where he just starts slinging
insults at people that he doesn't like
now I'm a podcast host I can sling
insults although I try not to
particularly on the basis of physical
appearance president Trump has no such
compunction here he goes after
pencil-neck Adam Schiff little
pencil-necked
Adam Schiff
it's got the smallest thinnest neck I've
ever seen he is not a long-ball hitter
but I saw him today well we don't really
know there could still have been some
Russia
[Applause]
okay's buddy it's also not useful but
it's funny but again he the president is
not a stand-up comedian is it smart for
him to be going back into stand-up
comedy mode this is what his base loves
about him I understand I understand a
lot of people find the center I find it
entertaining it is inherently funny this
is the thing about Trump that I think a
lot of folks in the media don't
understand folks on the Left don't
understand either
dudes actually pretty funny right dude
like he plays a room as though he's an
actual stand-up comedian is it smart
however to go after Adam Schiff on the
basis of his neck wouldn't you just go
after Adam Schiff by saying that he's a
dummy or a dunce or a or a liar like
that seems like a more solid grounding
on the basis of his neck making him he's
got a turkey neck like Jennifer Lopez
and Janie Gabba Gabba that actually was
not even the funniest thing that he said
last night the funniest thing that he
said last night he was talking for some
reason about the Great Lakes cuz
Michigan is in the Great Lakes region
and he starts talking about how much he
loves Lakes it's come on listen this
stuff is funny man
I support the Great Lakes always huh
they're beautiful they're big very deep
record deepness right I got nothing man
I got nothing again none of this is
gonna particularly hurt president Trump
is not gonna hurt him but his tendency
to be President Trump is exactly the
problem like there is a speech here
somewhere but it was buried inside a
comedy routine and the comedy routine
comedy is great for people who agree
with you comedy is not great for people
who really disagree with you unless it's
self-deprecating comedy self-deprecating
comedy is popular with pretty much
everybody
Trump has never made a self-deprecating
remarks oh it's nearly impossible to
imagine him doing that comedy is great
for all the people who like President
Trump or who agree with his agenda or
agree with him on these issues for
people who are torn on President Trump
it's not gonna do him any significant
favors and again I'm looking at this
from the strategic point of view not
from the is it funny point of view
because from the it's funny point of I
mean it's it's just damn hilarious
obviously now in a second we're gonna
get to president from sexual attacks on
Democrats because the less he focuses on
his victimization and the more he
focuses on their garbage Genda the
better he is going to do we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about that watch on your risk did you
did you spend a lot of money on that
watch is it a watch that measures like
how many steps you take every move you
make they'll be watching you isn't that
kind of watch or did you just get you
know a nice minimalist watch a watch
that really tells you the time and looks
nice because that's what movement
watches are all about you see this this
is a really nice watch this is a
movement watch behold it cast your eyes
upon it in despair that you have not won
but you could have a movement watch and
you could do so for a relatively
inexpensive price they have all sorts of
new styles and new features and they've
got watches and sunglasses and other
accessories movement watches are all
about looking good while keeping it
simple movement watches start at just 95
bucks you're looking at 400 bucks for
the same quality from a traditional
brand clean design minimalist really
quality products movement has sold
almost 2 million watches in over 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash shapiro movements
launching new styles on their site all
the time check out their latest at MVM
t-dot-com that's MBM
c-calm / Shapiro I love my movement
watch you will to join the movement
right now
MVM t.com / Shapiro ok so as we say
president Trump launches this Michigan
campaign really his 2020 re-election
campaign off the basis of the Mullen
report and that just shows you how
polarized our politics are because
usually the president launches his
reelection campaign on the basis of here
are all the great things that I've done
instead the president launches his
triumphant re-election campaign on the
basis of I'm not a Russian agent so the
goal posts have moved pretty radically
here and the Democrats are the ones who
move them here's where President Trump
however could be really effective and
that is attacking the Democratic agenda
because the Democratic agenda truly is
radical and most people understand that
he has two lines of attack here that are
really useful one is attacking the media
because people hate the media people
think the media are dishonest why well
because many in the media are in fact
dishonest whether they mean to be or
whether they do not mean to be their
confirmation bias makes it so they cover
the news in the least favorable way to
conservatives that you can possibly find
and that obviously holds true for anyone
who is even remotely right-of-center
including President Trump who I don't
think is actually an ideological
conservative so when Trump goes after
the media that's gonna be a popular line
with most Americans here's Trump saying
the media has to be held accountable
they have to be I'm sorry they have to
be accountable
and he is not wrong about that that line
was popular going all the way back to
Newt Gingrich in 2012 when he was
running for the nomination for the
Republican Party it continues to be
popular today nobody thinks the media
have done a good job on any of the stuff
so that is a fruitful line of attack for
president Trump casting aspersions at
the media that have attacked him
incessantly that attacks Bush
incessantly that attack everybody
right-of-center incessantly and people
who are not even right-of-center
so long as they disagree that will
continue to be a fruitful line of attack
but he's really gonna have to win on the
basis of pointing at the Democrats as I
have said all along if President Trump
were capable of just being quiet and
pointing right like Donald Sutherland in
that famous Jif right if you just stand
there like Donald Sutherland from
invasion of the body snatchers and
points in horror at the Democrats most
Americans would immediately recoil in
revulsion and what they saw because the
fact is the Democratic agenda is
extraordinarily radical and when
President Trump went after it last night
that's when he was in fact at his best
so here is the President of the United
States talking about Democrats and taxes
Radical Democrats are the party of high
taxes open borders late term abortion
crime hoaxes and illusions
[Applause]
the Republican Party is the party for
all Americans it's what we want to be
it's the way we want to live we're the
party of the American worker the
American family and we are the party of
the American dream okay all of that is
true and that should be the basis of his
campaign I think it will be I think it
will be if you can stay on teleprompter
and not talk too much about pencil necks
he doesn't like then I think the
president should probably be okay I'm
much more optimistic about his about his
hopes for 2020 than I was say six months
ago when it seemed like the Democrats
might in fact get their act together and
not be crazy
but now the Democrats continue to double
down on crazy we'll get to more of
president Trump's 2020 line of attack in
just a second so the president then
started to get into the details he
started talking about the green New Deal
the best boon that trump has ever
received is Alexandre Ocasio Cortez AOC
is the it'd of the Democratic Party in
the same way that Trump is the it'd of
the Republican Party AOC and her agenda
are nuts so nuts she didn't get a single
vote in favor of a green new zeal bill
co-sponsored by 12 separate senators on
the Democratic side of the aisle not one
of the co-sponsors of the bill voted for
the bill they all voted present on their
own bill here's President Trump going
after the stupid green New Deal again
this is going to be a fruitful line of
attack for Republicans and for the
president the Democrats are now
advancing an extreme 100 trillion dollar
government takeover called the green New
Deal
[Applause]
but I'd rather not talk about it tonight
because I don't want to talk them out of
it too soon because I love campaigning
against the green New Deal
I want them to make that a big part of
their platform
no more aeroplanes no more cows one car
per family one car you're gonna love
that in Michigan hey how do you like
that give one car per family I don't
think this is where Trump is at his best
comedy riffing on the Democrats yeah man
I'm in for it I'm in for it like really
this is this is good stuff
listen him go off on on the power of
windmills that Democrats have been
talking about the power of windmills for
a long time how wind power is suddenly
gonna power the United States fact if
you actually want it to equal the amount
of power that is currently being output
by all of the carbon-based fuel systems
in the United States not including
transportation right just the electrical
grid you would have to cover an area the
size of California in windmills that's
what you would have to do so good luck
with that here's President Trump going
after the windmills if Hillary got in
you wouldn't have that stat I can tell
you right that you'd be doing wind to
windmills being and if it doesn't if it
doesn't blow you can forget about
television for that night darling I want
to watch television I'm sorry the wind
isn't blowing
I know a lot about wind
[Laughter]
I know a lot about wind it's come on
he's so funny if you can't if you can't
laugh then you have a heart of stone he
is he is one of the reasons he's
president is because of this if also I
will say this negative Trump is not as
much fun as positive trumpet and this is
true for every politician politicians
who look like they're having a good time
or more likely to win this is true of
Obama in 2008 he looked like he was
having a better time than John McCain it
was true of 2012 Obama looked like he
was having a better time than Mitt
Romney it was sort of George W Bush who
always looked like he was having a
pretty good time
sour Trump is not going to be supremely
popular because people don't like sour
people but Trump laughing at the
Democrats along with people
it's not a bad look for him it really is
not and then President Trump goes after
the Democrats for wanting to destroy
people's private health insurance plans
he is not wrong about this either again
all he has to do is just point at the
Democrats if the American public focus
on President Trump leading up to 2020
he's gonna lose if they focus on the
Democrats he will win the Democrats are
pushing socialist government-run health
care that bans private health insurance
for 180 million American
now think of it a lot of you have
private plans and they're great they're
great and you want that they want to
take them away that's not gonna work I
don't think that's gonna work too well
of course all of that is true and then
from close after Democrats on abortion
and again here he is correct again this
clip twelve in recent months the
Democrat Party has also been
aggressively pushing extreme late term
abortion allowing children
to be ripped from their mother's womb
right up until the moment of birth and
now we go a step further in Virginia the
governor stated that he would even allow
a newborn baby wrap the baby up make the
baby comfortable to be executed okay
again all of this is accurate the press
will paint this as inaccurate it is in
fact not they're trying to paint it as
an accurate when he went to after the
green New Deal on the basis of even
Democrats not supporting it here is
Trump saying that mazie Hirono who is in
fact perhaps the dumbest person in the
United States Senate would say a hell of
a statement because there are a lot of
dummies there here's President Trump
suggesting that even mazie Hirono knows
that the Democratic green New Deal is a
mess she didn't know about the green New
Deal and the inner and she's from Hawaii
what do you think of the green New Deal
it was just put up by the Democrats well
I like it very much but she never saw it
then they said but you can't fly anymore
and she's in Hawaii
she said but how would I get to my
island they said we're working on some
kind of a train system so she said okay
well then I employ 100% it is the
craziest thing I've ever seen okay and
this of course is a little bit
apocryphal but it is true that mazie
Hirono did ask some questions about how
you would get rid of airplanes since she
has in fact the senator from Hawaii now
what are the obstacles for president
Trump leading up to 2020 well obstacle
number one is president Trump saying
stuff that is stupid right the president
Trump deciding to focus on issues that
the American people aren't really
focused on or him deciding to fulminate
about the molo report for the next
couple of years or him deciding that he
is simply gonna call names at the
Democrats as opposed to going after
their policies which is again as a
fruitful line of attack that could hurt
him because remember it's not just about
him getting out the base the Republicans
got out the base in 2018 and they lost
by eight point six points in the house
popular vote this is really gonna be
about can president Trump convince
suburban women that Democrats are too
dangerous for them he doesn't have to
convince them that he is the man for
suburban women he does have to convince
suburban women that voting against their
own interests would be a bad idea and
that the Democrats are so radical that
they'd be voting against their own
interests in voting for Democrats
obstacle number one is the president's
personality obstacle number two is going
to be the possibility of an economic
downturn and we are watching that the
economy is in fact slowing right now we
will see whether it slows enough to
actually slide into a downturn or
whether it maintains it's sort of
low-level growth he can survive a level
growth the downturns he's got a problem
and then obstacle number three is the
possibility that there are more
headlines that are bad for him in sort
of the muller michael cohen st NY stuff
i think that that possibility has been
reduced pretty dramatically i'll explain
why in just one second first let's talk
about your holster We the People
holsters they offer custom-made holsters
all produced in the USA they design
their own holsters in-house which means
they don't use any third-party molds for
their holsters instead they design every
unique mold in Las Vegas in order to
best fit every firearm perfectly they
constantly update designs they add new
designs every month that lets them stay
up to date on the newest models that
come out We the People holsters even
have their own 3d design team they
measure every micro
me to rub their guns to ensure the
perfect fit their unique intuitive clip
design allows for you to easily adjust
both the cans and the ride of your
holster so if it's comfortably and
securely at all times
every holster also has adjustable
retention which is signaled with a click
sound which lets you know that your
firearm is securely in place custom
printed designs in-house I mean these
are beautiful holsters I have one of
them they're terrific and they just
start at 37 bucks a piece every holster
comes with a lifetime guarantee every
holster also ships free so that is one
hell of a deal for a great holster if it
is not a perfect fit you send it back
for a refund right now my listeners can
go to We the People holsters comm slash
been enter promo code bent at checkout
and get ten bucks off their first
holster so that's as low as 37 bucks and
shipping is free an additional 10 bucks
off using my promo code so like 27 bucks
for a holster that is customized
essentially it's pretty amazing
again that's We the People holsters comm
slash been promo code been a check out
for 10 bucks off go check them out right
now great American company We the People
holsters dot-com / Ben though check them
out ok so as I say there is also the
possibility that more headlines arise
that are bad for president Trump in a
legal sense now I do think that the vast
majority of that is over I think that
it's over because the American public
had already moved toward the conclusion
that the Moller report was going to be a
nothing more Americans thought that it
was a quote unquote witch-hunt then
thought it was legit by the time that
the report was actually released by the
time that the top line findings were
released most Americans were tired of
this now they know the top-line findings
so if there's a 300 page report that
just reveals all the stuff we already
know about Trump I'm not sure that goes
anywhere also it casts everything in a
different light that Muller has already
exonerated Trump on the collusion stuff
now we look at all of the contacts
between members of the Trump team and
members of the Russian government and we
say yeah they're just doofuses before
you know normally there's so many human
actions where we can either attribute
malice or stupidity to people hey Adam
Carolla podcast host friend of mine
makes this point with regard to cops
pulling people over so what Adam says is
let's say you're pulled over unjustly
now you're not speeding you're pulled
over if you're a white guy you think of
as cop as a dummy if you are a black guy
you probably think oh this cop is a
racist which one is true well in all
likelihood it's that the person is
stupid because most people make mistakes
most people are dumb
most people make dumb mistakes and so if
you're looking at the actions of team
Trump and you are thinking that it was
all in the farías criminality and then
Muller comes down says none and I wasn't
nefarious criminality we looked at every
aspect of this it recasts everything as
comedic as opposed to tragic it recasts
everything as these people were just
dumb and incompetent as opposed to they
were maliciously trying to interfere
with the election and so you go back and
you look at people like george
papadapolis low-level Trump foreign
policy aide who met with a London
professor who was in fact a Russian
front and here's Papadopoulos explaining
that President Trump you know he went
when he was talking during the campaign
about how much he liked Vladimir Putin
that basically President Trump just
wanted a better relationship with Russia
that's all this was by the time I joined
the campaign in March of 2016 candidate
Donald Trump was obviously very vocal
about having some sort of working
relationship with Russia
I told Donald from to his face and Jeff
Sessions to his face at that infamous
March 31st meeting that I can do this
for you and I think it's in the interest
of the campaign Jeff Sessions was very
enthusiastic about it and I proceeded
until the campaign basically decided
that it was better not to I do think
there was obviously a strategic logic
behind working with Russia look at the
end of the day if we don't work with
Russia you know China is a huge threat
to US interests there in Syria there in
eastern Ukraine and that's what my firm
belief is why Donald Trump wanted to
work with Russia
so without Muller's report people would
say oh well this is obviously him lying
obviously who's trying to do was corrupt
the 2016 election with Muller's Report
just looks like the guy's being a dummy
same thing is true for Donald Trump jr.
meeting with that Russian lawyer Natalia
vessel nets kya Rob Goldstone was the
go-between he's a music agent he was the
go-between on that till he's the one
saying the Russians want to give you all
sorts of info about Hillary Clinton and
here is Rob Goldstone saying that Donald
Trump jr. was down the chain I mean this
is all just stupid stuff I never
considered Don jr. really a part of the
campaign you may have seen it again it's
in public testimony I questioned whether
I should send it to mr. Trump via some
method whether it's his assistant and
then I decided to go way down on the
food chain and I chose Don jr. because
I've met him a couple of times to run it
past him in
to put him in touch with my client I
think I was ignorant and oblivious and I
think if I had to guess he was
marginally more or marginally less
ignorant and oblivious than I was right
and that's absolutely plausible I mean
folks if you're not watching the video
if you can't actually see the video of
Rob Goldstone look at that guy and tell
me that he's a criminal mastermind who
is somehow linking up the Russian
government with the Trump campaign so as
to pervert America's elections ezza
doofus he's a doofus and so the Mullen
report does in many ways allow us to see
through the prism that I've been using
all along which is that most people are
stupid
rather than malicious nonetheless
Democrats are still trying to hang their
last hopes on the Mullen report they're
trying to suggest that maybe there's
something in the mellah report that was
not revealed in attorney General William
bars synopsis of the Mullen report The
Wall Street Journal reporting today
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi criticized
Attorney General William bar on Thursday
over his handling of the special
counsels report pressing the case for
the full release of the document as
president Trump and Republicans
continued to claim vindication in the
Russia probe Pelosi said that the
summary bar provided to lawmakers last
weekend was well short of what Congress
required show us the report and we can
draw our own conclusions she said she
said we don't need you interpreting it
for us to William bar said it was
condescending it was arrogant it wasn't
the right thing to do
right she would have preferred another
month of speculation over the Muller
report to simply understanding the
top-line results and revelation of the
report itself which will happen in the
next few weeks Kay this thing is not
going to remain secret Democrats who are
hoping that there will be some other
breaking news here's what's going to
happen
the 300-page report will come out there
will be a couple of details that we
didn't know about and the media will
blow these up to cataclysmic proportions
they will suggest that William bar the
Attorney General shut down in actual
obstruction charge that actually there
was deep corruption that actually even
though Muller concluded no collusion
there was in fact deep-seated collusion
and the American public will go nope
nope sorry you guys said that Muller was
going to save all of you he didn't so no
you're done you don't get a second bite
at this Apple you do not get a second
shot at that after you spend some twenty
five million dollars with 40 DOJ
attorneys on this case and worship at
the altar of robert muller he doesn't
give you what you want you don't get to
change your god now that is not
something that you get to do so I don't
think Trump is particularly vulnerable
there which means that the chief
tukoji president Trump's reelection is
not gonna be from Muller now maybe
there's an obstacle from the SDN why
maybe the Sen why brings down some sort
of campaign finance charge against
President Trump but even that I don't I
really don't see a world where the
American public care very much about
that sort of stuff it's all baked into
the cake the collusion stuff was not
baked into the cake it wasn't it might
have been the only thing not baked into
Trump's cake because it's so the
accusation was so incredibly wide broad
and and scary that if it had been true
it would have taken down Trump but
campaign finance stuff him paying off
ladies that I ain't gonna cut it that
ain't gonna cut it which means that the
chief obstacle to Trump's reelection
remains president Trump's personality
can he be disciplined in any way and if
he can be disciplined if he allows the
focus to be on the Democrats I think
that he has a pretty good shot at
reelection which is something I didn't
think I'd be saying six months ago okay
in a second we're gonna get to update
some adjusting somewhat case and we'll
jump into the mailbag but first go
subscribe over daily we're calm we had a
great episode of daily we're backstage
last night if you were a subscriber you
could have asked questions in fact if
you subscribe to during the broadcast of
backstage last night then you actually
had a shot at coming out here we would
have flown you out here put you up in a
hotel and allowed you to come watch the
daily wire backstage and suffer along
with me listening to Michael moles talk
while wearing shorts that could have
been you in that room suffering I know
it sounds more like a threat than an
incentive but it is actually as a thank
you to our daily wear your annual
subscribers even for 99 bucks year you
get the annual subscription which comes
along with this the greatest in beverage
vessels that left his tears hot or cold
tumbler you can go get that right now
and as a thank you to our daily water
annual subscribers we give a shout out
to a different subscriber each Friday
today carnac the magnificent at Biff
NOLA we would like to thank you for
being a magnificent subscriber with a
name like Karnak I can't say I'm
surprised I expected it you can see in
this photo the Karnak magnificent has
placed his leftist ears tumblr next to
his shower drain which is wise and
prudent because this week leftist yours
Tumblr's across the land were
overflowing there were reports of flash
floods was actually very dangerous we
urge our subscribers to emulate Karnak
and place their tumblers near to high
capacity drains until further notice
Carnac the magnificent thank you for
being a subscriber we appreciate it and
if you want a chance at being featured
on the show
become a daily water annual subscriber
right now post a photo of
tumblr on Twitter or Instagram you can
even be in the photo if you'd like
unless Carnac is the shower grin in
which case he is in the photo so that's
exciting
okay go check all of that out you get
all sorts of goodies two additional
hours a day we're working hard for the
money I mean we are working hard for you
folks we've got an entire team of people
working hard to bring you great content
every day what comes out is very often
mediocre but you're just gonna have to
deal with that go check it out right now
annual subscription ninety nine bucks a
year also subscribe YouTube iTunes so
many goodies I didn't even mention when
you become a subscriber leave us a
review at iTunes by the way that always
helps us in the rankings we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so updates in the justice
Millette case President Trump did not
leave the justice Millette case alone he
jumped into it and people on the Left
who are ripping him for doing this I
have a couple of words for you Barack
Obama Ferguson Missouri Barack Obama New
York Barack Obama Trayvon Martin Barack
Obama Henry Louis Gates okay so I'm not
a big fan of the President of the United
States jumping into what are effectively
local scandals Trump didn't start this
process here's President Trump going
after justice Millette
absolute embarrassment to our country
and I have asked that it be that they
look at it I think that case is an
absolute embarrassment to our country
and somebody has to at least take a very
good hard look at it okay and he is not
wrong about this they are taking a good
hard look at this right now
Illinois prosecutors Bar Association may
be looking at this barring Kim Fox the
the state's attorney in this case they
put out a statement yesterday saying the
Illinois prosecutors Bar Association
serves as the voice for nearly 1,000
frontline prosecutors across the state
who work tirelessly toward the pursuit
of justice the events are the past few
days regarding the Cook County State's
Attorney's handling of the justice
Millette case is not condoned by the IP
BA nor is it representative of the
honest ethical work prosecutors provides
the citizens of the state of Illinois on
a daily basis the manner in which this
case was dismissed was abnormal and
unfamiliar to those who practice law in
criminal court houses across the state
prosecutors defense attorneys judges
alike do not recognize the arrangement
mr. Smollett received I mean this is
brutal
even more problematic the state's
attorneys and her representatives have
fundamentally misled the public on the
law and the circumstances surrounding
the dismissal the public has the right
to know the truth we set out to do that
here when an elected state attorney
recuse herself from a prosecution
Illinois law provides the court shall
appoint a special prosecutor here the
state's attorney kept the case within
her office and thus never actually
recused herself as a matter of law
additionally the Cook County State's
Attorney's Office falsely informed the
public that the uncontested ceiling of
the Criminal Court case was mandatory
under Illinois law this statement is now
accurate to the extent the case was even
eligible for an immediate seal that
action was discretionary not mandatory
and only upon a proper filing of a
motion to seal the state's attorney not
only to decline decline to fight the
sealing of this case in court she then
provided false information to the public
regarding it the appearance of
impropriety here is compounded by the
fact that this case was not on the
regularly scheduled court call the
public had no reasonable notice or
opportunity to view the proceedings and
the dismissal was done abruptly at what
has been called an emergency hearing to
date the nature of the purported
emergency has not been publicly
disclosed the ceiling of a court case
immediately following a hearing where
there was no reasonable notice or
opportunity for the public to attend is
a matter of grave public concern and
undermines the very foundation of our
public court system lastly the state's
attorney has claimed this arrangement is
available to all defendants and not a
new or unusual practice there has even
been an implication it was done in
accordance with a statutory diversion
program these statements are plainly
misleading and inaccurate this action
was highly unusual not a statutory
diversion program and not in accordance
with well accepted practices of state's
attorney initiated diversionary programs
the IP PA supports I version programs
and recognizes the many benefits they
provide to the community the defendants
and the prosecuting agency central to
any diversion program however is that
the defendant must accept responsibility
to be clear here this simply was not a
deferred prosecution we strongly
encourage our members in the public to
review the National District Attorneys
Association statement on prosecutorial
best practices in high-profile cases and
that is a letter from the president of
the Illinois prosecutors Bar Association
I would not be surprised at Kim Fox who
ends up disbarred here and she should be
disbarred this is absurd it's absurd by
the way a statement - USA Today and
Wednesday shows that a top aide to
Michelle Obama addressed reports that
she had emailed Cook County State's
Attorney Kim Fox to request on behalf of
the simal s that the investigation be
taken out of the hands of Chicago PD she
acknowledges that she did that I mean
this is it's amazing stuff it's an
amazing case and again the fact that
this was dismissed Kim Fox may find
herself in the legal crosshairs and she
probably should because she has allowed
justice Millette to continue maintaining
his innocence in
most absurd ridiculous and insane way as
we mentioned yesterday
Chelsea Smuts attorneys are going out
there and now claiming that when jussie
Smollett hired these two Nigerian
brothers to attack him in in in the city
of Chicago when he did that and then
described them as white people to police
he wasn't lying to police maybe it was
the Nigerian brothers wearing white face
to attack him in a hoax in a fit in a
hate crime that he was not involved in
in the first place
naturally the Nigerian brothers lawyers
they're like this is insane
you're suggesting that my clients wore
white face underneath a ski mask that's
your claim he said that the brothers
could have been wearing white face at
night I I heard that and I think that's
absolutely just atrocious it adds to I
think why people are giving lawyers a
bad name it's to to distract from the
real issues here and right by putting
out conspiracy theories that perhaps my
clients were wearing white face it just
adds to the ridiculous
and and the offensiveness of this entire
thing yeah the fact that the media are
even taking seriously that contention
demonstrates in actual racial bias on
the part of the media and that is they
will grant a lot more credibility to
somebody like Jesse Smollett than if it
were a white person who are declaring
some sort of crime had been committed
against them falsely there's just no
question that the media are doing that
the media are granting splat all sorts
of credibility they would not grant you
anybody else and it's insane it's fully
crazy but that's not unusual the media
are apparently willing to condone racism
depending on the person from whom at the
racism emanates because the broader
narrative is that America is racist
against black people not that people
like Jesse Smollett are seeking to
slander white people as racist against
people like Jesse Smollett another
indicator that the media are willing to
are willing to not only look the other
way but incentivize this sort of racism
comes in today's New York Times there's
an article in today's New York Times by
a person named Christopher divas it is
called this quote I broke up with her
because she's white when it comes to
dating I'd rather not think about race
but that's been hard to avoid this
entire op-ed
in the new york times is about a man who
says that he will no longer date white
women because he's uncomfortable dating
white women he says over the years I've
dated brown women and black women but
mostly white women I hadn't thought
about why that was well in some brown
and black people in my communities
started giving me a hard time about
dating white women
I sensed they'd be happier if I stopped
I also got weird vibes from some white
people namely the parents of the woman
that I was dating the ones who asked me
if I speak Mexican that is absolutely a
thing the real reason I think I can no
longer date white women isn't any of
that it's because in today's hashtag
woke society there's mad pressure to be
hashtag woke to be aware of the
implications of whom you're attracted to
and why which means that in the eyes of
others the color of the women I date is
a big deal like I'm the problem like I'm
betraying my people if I date white
women but I was taught that we were all
one people I see people watching me with
the stink-eye noses turned up as if they
think black and brown people would
somehow be better off if I dumped my
white girlfriend it's a lot of pressure
and then he says he started reading
James Baldwin Donaghy C Coates another
black and brown authors looking for
guidance a road map he'll help on what
it means to be a brown man in the world
like yes our bodies have been colonized
yes I am a child of blackness how did we
get here if everybody is to woke why are
things so terrible
maybe maybe everybody isn't so woke and
so he says that he stopped dating white
women because he had doubts about how
society sees him pretty amazing stuff
pretty amazing stuff but the New York
Times prints that piece it's it's just
incredible okay you know let's do a
little bit of mailbag mica says hey Ben
I'm a huge fan of the show I was talking
about capital punishment the other day
with a friend and was wondering what
your view was concerning capital
punishment a lot of people say it's
right because murderers can't decide
when to end someone's life but the
rebuttal is that if they can't neither
can the justice system no that's that's
a bad rebuttal because normally you're
not allowed to kidnap people and keep
them in a locked room for 20 years
the justice system can do that if you
have committed a crime so the justice
system exists for two purposes one is
retributive justice Yeti you paid the
court you did the crime you do the time
and the other is protection of you from
the public some people think
rehabilitation is in the cards for the
justice system typically speaking
rehabilitation programs have not been
wildly successful there are some success
stories but overall not so much when
people talk about the decline in crime
rates that's not the success of
rehabilitation systems
that is the the so-called mass
incarceration that's taken place lots of
criminals going to prison means fewer
criminals out on the street as far as
capital punishment in concept I'm in
favor of capital punishment the way that
it's practiced currently in the United
States I have serious doubts about it
there there certainly people who deserve
to die if you rape and murder a child
you should be put to death if however we
are only doing this on a sporadic basis
and you sit 30 years on death row and
you get tons of Appeals and the and the
criminal justice system only unevenly
applies the death penalty not based on
crime then I've got some I think there
are serious questions to be asked about
the system of the death penalty in the
United States but the application of the
death penalty to particular people I
don't know we have a huge problem with
that John says hi Ben congratulations on
the new book mine is on the way well I
appreciate it
the book by the way right side of
history free pitch for you I was
wondering what your view is on
birthright citizenship as a part of the
14th amendment was that concept intended
in the actual text of the law itself
back when it was written or is it a more
modern legal interpretation thanks for
your thoughts have a great weekend this
is a very controversial area of
constitutional law so the idea of
birthright citizenship does have some
roots in English common law yeah if you
were born in Britain you were a citizen
of Britain with that said it is true
that in the 14th amendment it says born
in the United in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof
meaning that if you are a citizen of a
foreign country and you have a baby here
that baby may be subject to the
jurisdiction of the foreign country
which is why for example diplomats who
have kids in the United States their
kids don't become automatic American
citizens because they are subjected to a
foreign jurisdiction I think there's a
pretty good case to be made that the
Fourteenth Amendment was not meant to
apply to everybody that it wasn't meant
to apply to everyone born in the United
States with that said it's obviously
embedded in both American law and
American politics at this point it's not
going to end anytime soon and and thus I
think that it's it's sort of a moot
point on practical grounds if you want
to read the two sides of this I believe
John u has written in favor of
birthright citizenship and I know that
the folks over at the Center for
Immigration Studies including people
like John Eastman have written against
birthright citizenship you can read both
sides of the case there Oprah says hey
Ben if a Democrat becomes president in
the future how would this affect the
us-israeli relations with the
recognition of
rue salam and the golan heights be
overruled or even worse i don't know the
answer to that considering the anti
semitic direction of the democratic
party open anti-semites in the
democratic party have now been approved
they've been given the stamp of approval
i have proof for this here's barack
obama a picture of barack obama today
with Rasheeda Talib Rasheeda Talib is an
anti-semite Rasheeda Talib has suggested
that Jewish Americans and Israel
supporters are subject to dual loyalty
she has supported groups that have
connections to terrorism like care she
she is a supporter of the of the racist
anti-semitic and and evil boycott
divestment sanctions program which is
largely sponsored by advocates of terror
particularly the Middle East here she is
with Barack Obama and listen I think
taking a picture next to a politician
doesn't mean that you endorse everything
the politician does but this is a little
bit different here's what she tweeted
Barack Obama met met with us new members
of Congress and we had a thoughtful
discussion about serving our country the
best part was when he looked straight at
me and said I'm proud of you for what
for what by the way it also came out
today that Barack Obama's administration
was planning the unleashing of that
horrible evil UN Security Council
resolution that condemned Israel for
defending itself in 2016 mm from
resolution condemning Israel it was
Obama's administration reportedly
according to a former Obama aide who
coordinated that resolution so I'm very
afraid for the future of us-israel
relations if the Democrats re-enter
power because obviously the base of the
party doesn't like Israel they've
decided that that the basis of social
justice requires them to support
Israel's enemies despite the fact that
Israel is in every way more free
democratic and liberal than any of the
countries that surround it and that
certainly includes the terror the
terrorists govern Palestinians and again
even the Palestinians recognize how
terrible things are now I mean many are
rising up in in Gaza the media are
ignoring it because they would prefer to
focus on Israel Jacob says Haven
longtime listener first-time subscriber
my first act as a subscriber is this
question what is the reasoning behind
senator Harris's theme music and
shouldn't it be definitely Snoop Tupac
for sure also if you will where do you
think the future of space exploration
lies has government ruined that too
I think that the future of space
exploration lies in private industry
you're seeing that with Elon Musk right
now and the SpaceX program and I think
that's good I don't think that
governments necessarily have to be the
driving force behind space exploration
with that said do I think that the the
American space program has been
underfunded I do because not only has it
provided an enormous technological
improvement it is also a common goal to
which I think we can aspire it's it's
it's a pretty cool thing just yeah there
are very few things in American
government where I say it's cool so we
should fund it I think maybe the space
program is the the only exception to my
general rule as we'll discuss in a
little while and things I hate
as far as her music we picked the music
from dragnet because the critique of
Kamala Harris is that she is a narc I'm
not making fun of her Tupac and Snoop
fanship largely because the media
portray any anyway UID if I had picked a
theme song for Kamala Harris that was
rap for example the media would have
suggested that is racist even if I had
said this I'm picking this because she
said she likes this music hey that's how
that's how the media treat this sort of
stuff that's how Media Matters treats
this sort of stuff and so I prefer to
pick music that I think embodies her
image in the Democratic primaries rather
than music that she herself has said she
likes Sarah says hey Ben two questions
my sister and I got into a fight
recently because she thinks she would
prefer the label of libertarians to the
one of conservative I believe I've heard
you reference conservatism more often
can you clarify which label you more
closely identify with so I hate to split
the baby when it comes to government
involvement and libertarian when it
comes to the relationship between
government and to the social fabric I'm
conservative what I mean by that is that
my critique of libertarianism is that
libertarianism seems to suggest that the
social fabric is unimportant that or at
least less important than I think it
should be the basis for a free
government has to be in a strong social
fabric and that lies historically in
conservatism also the idea of
conservatism is that there is something
to conserve libertarianism doesn't focus
too much on the culture that it seeks to
conserve instead it simply says that you
should be able to do whatever you want
so long as the government is not
involved and I think that libertarianism
as a government philosophy is good I
think libertarianism as a life
philosophy leave something to be desired
she says there
since I've heard your explanation of
convention of states was immediately
excited by the possibility as I've been
supporting it on social media I've
gotten feedback from both left and right
leaning friends who say it is more
dangerous than helpful the common
argument is no rules govern a convention
of states and with our political climate
it's dangerous to be opening the power
to changing the Constitution as someone
who is nearly a single-issue voter on
the Second Amendment I'm becoming more
concerned that convention gone rogue in
this climate could lead to an abolition
of my most cherished freedoms what do
you think about these criticisms are
these concerns serious so I am not
seriously concerned about a a convention
of states going rogue because all of the
amendments that are proposed at a
convention of states still actually have
to be approved by the vast majority of
states the I mean I can I can read you
article 5 of the Constitution let me
bring up the actual text so article 5 of
the Constitution which deals with how
the Constitution is to be amended
suggests that Congress whenever
two-thirds of both houses shall deem it
necessary shall propose amendments to
the Constitution or on the application
of the Legislature's of two-thirds of
the several states shall call a
convention for proposing amendments
which in either case shall be valid to
all intents and purposes as part of this
constitution when ratified this is the
part when ratified by the Legislature's
of three-quarters of the several states
or by conventions in three-quarters
thereof as the one or the other mode of
ratification may be proposed by Congress
and so that is that that's the key
element is that when people talk about a
runaway convention of states you would
need three quarters of the legislators
or conventions in three quarters that
have been certified by the legislatures
to actually approve of the amendments so
I'm not too worried about the abolition
of the Second Amendment three quarters
of the states are not going to vote to
get rid of the Second Amendment so I'm
in favor of the convention of states
because I think that there could be some
things done many people who are
interested in convention of states have
have said that they are behind term
limits that's actually not something I
love I don't really like term limits
very much because it seems to me that
very often they do more harm than good
but I am in favor of attempts to
restructure the executive branch
particularly I may be in favor of term
limits before the Supreme Court I'm not
a huge fan of life lifetime appointments
to the Supreme Court particularly and
I'm very much in favor of the idea that
we should pass amendments there
strict bills - single issues as opposed
to these omnibus packages that allow
legislators to escape the consequences
of their own votes Nikolas says hey men
would you ever consider concealed
carrying a firearm if California made it
remotely possible
do you support national reciprocity be
national reciprocity for concealed carry
thanks for all you do I do support
and absolutely I would consider
concealed carrying a firearm I mean I
get a lot of threats there are a lot of
people who are not fans and if I could
concealed carry a firearm I would be
much more comfortable in fact I may
apply for a concealed carry permit even
in LA County because of the number of
threats that I get Anthony says hey man
congratulations on your book landing at
the top of the New York Times bestseller
list I wanted to ask you your thoughts
on stay-at-home dads I've always wanted
to be a father I'm willing to take on
that role if my future spouse wants to
focus on a career but is that a role
that should be held predominantly by
mothers many of my male Christian
friends around me seem to think that
women can only respect men if they are
the breadwinners and it's got me
thinking twice about my open attitude to
being a stay-at-home dad thanks for
everything you and TDW team do so my dad
was a stay-at-home dad my mom worked my
dad was the stay-at-home dad if you want
to be a stay-at-home dad I don't see
anything wrong with that traditionally
women have been the ones who stay at
home with the kids because they have
more of a drive to do that because women
and men are generally built differently
that's why women take more time off from
the workplace to be at home with their
kids I can see it in my wife when my
wife finishes her residency she wants to
spend a lot more time at home with my
kids I can call a call my shots I run my
own business I work a lot there is a
difference between men and women in so
far as how they want to interact with
children on a general level but on an
individual level if you want to be a
stay-at-home dad and your wife is cool
with that I don't have any problem with
that at all do I think that it's
important that that spouses respect each
other sure so if your spouse is going to
even innately feel that she doesn't
properly respect you because you're not
out earning a living so to speak that's
something you should take into
consideration because a healthy marriage
is the basis of healthy child-rearing as
well Rafael says hey Ben what do you
think about gerrymandering are you
following the case in the Supreme Court
how would you rule I think that the the
question of gerrymandering being a
partisan issue has been overblown
radically despite all of these supposed
gerrymandering that makes it impossible
for Democrats to be elected they just
want a sweeping victory in the house so
all of the talk about
gerrymandering ruins the system there is
no good way to draw these lines and the
attempt to create nonpartisan
commissions they never end up being
nonpartisan and then they're
unanswerable which is a problem TJ says
I've been I'm reading a book right side
of history it's awesome I understand the
morality of something given by God and
it's our job to establish the logic so
people could be persuaded to follow the
moral norms in the Ten Commandments God
specifically forbids murder and adultery
do you think euthanasia and prostitution
can be considered murder and adultery if
yes what would be your logic to explain
that and what's your take on those two
issues I appreciate everything that you
do so I am anti euthanasia I think that
the idea of doctor sponsored killings is
deeply dangerous in the moral fabric of
a society now I think there's a
difference between that and
quote-unquote withholding care and so if
you are on your if you're a brain-dead
and you're on life support and the life
support is withdrawn because you can't
live on your own I don't think that's
the same thing as actively injecting
poison into your veins to kill you in
terms of preserving life I'm against you
I don't think that's a doctor it's not a
doctor's job to kill you I mean it
violates the basic precepts of the
Hippocratic oath which I know we have
forgotten about as far as prostitution
can it be considered adultery it depends
where you can set are you committing
adultery when you're with a prostitute
so on a moral level prostitution is a
grave evil because the commodification
of sex is deeply dangerous again to the
moral fabric of a society does that mean
it should be illegal not sure it does
you should at euthanasia be illegal I
think you should a the euthanasia should
remain illegal because the taking of
human life even with consent is not
something that we should be in favor of
human life ought to be protected that is
one of the fundamental concerns of
government and your permission is not
required to protect your life Cassandra
says what is your opinion on abortion in
cases in which the baby is 100% non
viable ie no skull missing organs
rearranged body parts etc sometimes not
discovered until after the heartbeat
well in those rare cases the non
viability of the baby is typically it's
typically results in miscarriage
biologically speaking you know there are
cases of non abortion right DNC's that
that occur when for example there is a
baby in utero that no longer has a
heartbeat so essentially it's a floating
corpse at that point you're not talking
about the taking of human life so I have
no problem with with
see in that particular case if you're
talking about a baby that that is not
going to be born healthy but it's still
alive I think that you are getting into
dangerous moral territory especially
because there are cases where they
actually get it wrong you know I know
multiple parents who have been told that
their babies are going to have severe
abnormalities and the babies don't
actually end up having severe
abnormalities I'm not in favor of
precipitous ending of human life even
for purposes of non-viability Phillippe
says what is the purpose of art in
society what is the importance of art
generally well the purpose of art is to
beautify life and to contain eternal
truths in temporary or somewhat
permanent form art beautifies life I
mean that's just what it is now does art
make you more moral no it depends on the
message of the art depends what art does
when people say that art Nobel's some of
the great art in human history was
created right in the lead-up to World
War two in Germany and that did not
enable art doesn't I mean Germany was
probably the most cultured country on
planet earth at the time the Nazis arose
so there is no necessary linkage between
the quality of art and the quality of
the human beings who either produce that
art or consume that art but there's no
question that art beautifies life okay
final question Matthews has been as you
know people often point to a conspiracy
theory about Zionist Jews can you
explain why this is typically a front
for anti-semitism sure because the
conspiracy doesn't exist so
anti-semitism is itself a conspiracy
theory it's a suggestion that the Jews
band together in secretive evil groups
and that they control the markets or
they control foreign policy or they
control this or they control that and
then that is used as a way to target
Jews and to hurt Jews because obviously
if the Jews are secretly powerful then
we have to do something to take them
down a peg it's different than other
forms of racism most forms of racism are
based on the innate inferiority of a
particular group of people anti-semitism
is based on the threat of this supposed
group of people that Jews are innately
threatening because they have these
secret connections with one another it's
a bunch of nonsense the the conspiracy
theories about Zionism that Zionists all
over the world are controlling form pop
it's obviously untrue I mean the EU is
really anti-israel as a general rule the
United States Democratic Party is not in
favor of Israel increasingly which is
really sad there's still some old guard
folks like Stinney Hoyer who are but
that's as a minority movement it seems
it no one seems to be able to explain if
the Jews are so all-powerful why are
they constantly getting slaughtered an
incredible rate and why is it that even
in a state that they've developed from
nothing like legitimately nothing from
swampland and sand they've developed a
thriving state why is that state
constantly under attack and the Jews are
expected to somehow take it on the chin
from people firing rockets into their
civilian areas in the name of social
justice or some such nonsense okay time
for a quick thing that I like then we'll
do a quick thing I hate cuz I was a long
mailbag so things that I like there are
a bunch of movies that I've been
watching at night because they I have to
sign a lot of books I mean thank God a
lot of people bought right side of
history I have to sign legitimately tens
of thousands of books now so that means
that each night I basically watch a
movie and then sign 2,000 books so there
was one that I watched the other night
that actually didn't get nearly any play
but is a good interesting movie I love
westerns I'm a huge fan of westerns and
the the acting particularly in this
Western is terrific john c reilly
joaquin phoenix jake gyllenhaal it's
it's called the sisters brothers it
barely got any play at all because it's
it's weird it's not a usual western but
it does raise serious sort of moral
questions about how people live in the
world about the value of family about
good and evil I thought it was kind of a
fascinating film it's called the sisters
brothers here's a little bit of the
preview
[Music]
the sisters brothers sis ter F people
he'll acknowledge that I think Joaquin
Phoenix may be the best actor working
today and I cannot wait honestly for his
joke removing I was very much against
the concept of a joker movie because the
Joker doesn't have an origin story but
with that said I mean the acting and
this is really first-rate Jake
Gyllenhaal is terrific in it as well so
if you like good acting and you like
westerns then this is a movie for you
it's got a lot of gunfire but not a lot
of interesting gunplay but it's it's
interestingly filmed in there there's a
lot to like about this film the sisters
brothers go check it out I think it's on
demand right now okay time for some
things that I hate so I hate dishonesty
in media coverage particularly when it
comes to the when it comes to the
coverage of government spending so
there's a lot of hubbub over the past
few days about the Secretary of
Education Betsy DeVos proposing a budget
that did not fund the Special Olympics
the Special Olympics does not need
public funding it doesn't and people
give tons of money to the Special
Olympics the Special Olympics is a
wonderful thing it is it's terrific I
would give money to the Special Olympics
that seed Abbas gives money to the
Special Olympics but the implication is
that if you don't want the government
signing a check to things that can be
privately supported that somehow you are
cruel this is a bizarre contention are
we supposed to identify compassion
simply with government spending so if I
sign a cheque to a charity and then I
say you know what I don't think the
government should excise taxpayer money
to support that charity because there
are lots of people like me who support
that institution does this somehow make
me non compassionate toward the very
charity to which I sign a cheque that
was the implication that was made about
Betsy DeVos the Secretary of Education
it's just nonsense it's just silly
the federal government supplies
something like 18 million dollars to the
Special Olympics and I understand it's
bad optics to quote unquote defund at
the Special Olympics but let's be real
about this the Special Olympics doesn't
actually need the money hey all Trump
had to do if Trump wanted to actually do
something good on this what he should
have said is Betsy DeVos is correct the
Special Olympics
not require public funding and I'll show
you why they don't require public
funding I'm giving a million dollars and
I'm gonna tweet out to all my supporters
let's fill that gap and show that the
American people are big hearted and
kind-hearted and that we don't need to
spend taxpayer dollars to get this done
it would've raised twice the amount of
money the federal government spends in
legitimately about an hour because the
American people are warm-hearted and
generous and we don't have to
demonstrate that through tax policy
nonetheless because of public pressure
President Trump backed down on this and
he said that he was going to fund the
Special Olympics instead of using this
as a teachable moment as a learning
opportunity for people showing that the
American people are insanely generous
when it comes to good causes will be
funded I just told my people
I want to fund the Special Olympics and
I just authorized a funding of the
Special Olympics I've been to the
Special Olympics I think it's incredible
and I just authorised a funding I heard
about it this morning
I have overridden my people with funding
the Special Olympics I mean again the
the falling for the democratic narrative
which is that you don't have sympathy
for something unless you publicly fund
it is dangerous to the health of the
Republic and to the health of
conservatism I've gotten the same thing
when it comes to school lunch programs
so I've said before I think school lunch
programs are a giant fail speaking you
know just statistically they are kids
are more likely to be obese if they're
on a school lunch program than if they
are just bringing lunch from home the
statement that I have made about school
lunch programs is if you want to deal
with systemic poverty school lunch
programs ain't gonna do it and it is
also true that as a parent you should be
incentivized to get food for your child
this is literally your first priority
his horner I mentioned Adam Carolla
earlier on the program it's school lunch
programs that made Adam Carolla into a
libertarian because he would go to
school and they would serve him this
slop and then you'd go home and see his
parents sitting around on their welfare
check instead of actually making sure
that he had a healthy lunch now this
this seems to me like the very basis of
being a parents if you cannot feed your
kids basic I mean we spent tens of
thousands of dollars on welfare programs
for poor households in the United States
if you can't feed your kids despite that
massive social safety net in the United
States you shouldn't have those kids in
your house seriously if your kid child
starvation in the United States is not a
problem
systemic proverty may be a problem child
starvation is not in fact a problem when
you say this sort of stuff it's
Oh will you lacks empathy really I lacks
empathy how much charity did you give
last year it's it's the the
identification of compassion with
government spending is a dangerous thing
and again I think Trump could have done
something much more interesting here if
he had chosen to instead he sort of
moved on with it which i think is a bad
move already well we will be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours this weekend go pick up
a copy of the right side of history I
know was barely in book stores a lot of
the bookstores weren't even really
carrying it this week
then it shocked the world and became
number one on the New York Times
bestseller list so it should be
available in book stores this week and
go pick up a copy of my new best-selling
book the right side of history tell all
your friends about it and either we'll
see you here this afternoon if you
subscribe and you listen to radio or
we'll see you here next week have a
wonderful weekend I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today we're going to discuss what I
think is an epidemic of groupthink in
our society people seem to be less and
less I'm sure you've noticed this people
are less and less willing and able to
think for themselves form their own
ideas and opinions and perspectives so
I'd like to analyze that problem also
justice Millette lawyer has come up with
a really hilarious and pitiful alibi
excuse for for justice Millette peta
embarras it's embarrassing itself yet
again and I want to deal with the claim
very common claim you hear all the time
that Jesus was just a polite nice guy
who never would have insulted or
confronted anyone I think that's total
nonsense of course so we'll talk about
all of that today on the Matt Walsh show